right so I'd like to thank the
organizers for inviting me to come here
and talk and hopefully you'll all find
it a little bit interest
this is mainly going to be about what we
do at Diamond light source and how we
use Python there to do various different
everyday things so basically I'm going
to talk a little bit about what diamond
light sources so that you've all got an
idea of where I actually work and the
problems that we have a little bit about
Big Data so I was asked about can I give
a talk about Big Data so I'm going to
talk about the types of big data that we
have and I'm gonna do a little bit about
Python for scientists and a bit about
Python for developers I think you can
treat them in two different ways so
first things first diamond light source
is a particle accelerator in South
Oxfordshire it's about the size of
Wembley Stadium which is excellent cuz i
can actually pointed it i normally can't
do that for a talk it's about the size
of wembley stadium and basically it's
i'll show you the video so it makes a
lot more sense it basically we
accelerate electrons to very near the
speed of light and we use them to
generate really really intense x-ray
beams so I mean mass other way so
basically this is just the outside
there's two sorts of parts to it there's
the main synchrotron building which is
where the accelerator is and in the
other room or the other building is
where everybody who sort of just
generally works on it lives we're on the
ground floor because there isn't the
basement for the computer programmers
and if you if you pull the roof off
basically where there's three main parts
as a linear accelerator a booster
synchrotron and a main storage ring and
the idea is that we have bunches of
electrons we put them in the linear
accelerator and we accelerate them up to
about ninety nine point nine nine
percent the speed of light then go into
the booster synchrotron and are
accelerated up to three GeV which is
ninety-nine point nine nine nine nine
nine nine nine percent speed of light
and then we put them into the storage
ring where they generate a really bright
x-ray light for us so here we go as a
little bunch of particles that are
electrons at the bottom they go into the
booster synchrotron spin up and then
eventually they'll go now into the main
storage ring and then you'll see them
start emitting light now basically they
emit light to every single one of these
beam lines that around the outside here
and as I say the light that they emit is
incredibly bright it's about a million
times brighter than the Sun it's about a
billion times brighter than a hospital
x-ray machine very very intense light we
general
and that's actually part of the problem
when you've got very intense light you
can use very short shutter speeds for
doing for doing exposures now this is
our little bunch of electrons and what
we do to generate the light is we wiggle
it from left to right through a magnetic
field so it's an array of magnets and
then it basically drops the photons off
down into the beam line and the electron
beam goes around the corner remember
that for later because there's a partly
I'm going to talk about where we talking
a little bit more about that as I say
the synchrotrons there we've got various
beam lines around the outside and
effectively each one of those beamlines
gets x-ray light of some form or another
but can use them in completely different
ways so each one of these different
experimental stations can do totally
different things so what do I do well I
provide one part of the software or data
analysis scientific software group I
provide data analysis for use during and
after Ben time for users a lot of our
users may not have any prior experience
of how synchrotron works so we get a lot
of people who have people like
archaeologists paleontologists you come
along and they just want to use the
equipment as a way of looking at their
sample they don't want to know how to
reconstruct the data or anything like
this so we try to give them really
useful data they can take home rather
than the raw experimental data as about
30 beam lines with about a hundred
different techniques that are used we
transport that with its myself and about
12 other full-time people so we're
relatively stretched on how much we can
actually provide to each of these groups
so why am I talking in a Python
conference well it's good to start to
see where it all started before diamond
light source which is about 2007 there
was another synchrotron at Dyess buri
and they started in about 2,000 to
writing a piece of software called the
GDA which is written in java and
basically the GDA is generic data
acquisition and it's basically there to
run all of our beam lines so that we're
all using the same piece of software and
all other beam lines for controlling the
motors doing scans of doing all these
kinds of things in about 2004 it was
really appreciated that actually a key
thing that would be really useful is
some way of scripting this so that the
scientists rather than the software
developers could actually really
increase the ability of what the
software could do they could optimize
things they could write
kinds of different codes to improve the
beamline do scans do all kinds of
exciting data collections and jython was
picked as the language because it's that
neatly on top of java allowed you to
access all the java objects behind the
scenes and it was relatively simple
syntactically people could get the hang
of it what this meant was that we ended
up with much much faster being my set at
times and data collection speeds were
increased made it a lot easier for
people to use the equipment that leads
us nicely onto well why am I talking
about big data making the beamline
easier to use means that people can
collect more data also we've got this
kind of universal data problem if you
bought a mobile phone recently you may
well have a 41 megapixel camera on it
that's just insanity we're getting
exactly the same problem with
experimental detectors in that they're
just getting bigger and bigger and
faster and to give you an example in
2007 when we had first users our data
are collectors or beamline systems were
running about 10 megabytes per second
absolute max speed 2009 we got some
really cool kit from Switzerland and
that suddenly started running about 60
megabytes per second 2011 they managed
to make that even faster 150 megabytes
per second okay so we're now no longer
able to deal with this with one gigabyte
networking sorry one gigabit networking
we have to go to 10 gig networking for
these pieces of equipment 2013 we've now
at about 10 machines or 10 systems which
have 10 gig links and we've got six
hundred megabytes per second data
collection systems these can run almost
continuously onto disk and in 2015 we're
looking at a new detector that can do
six gigabytes per second it's absolute
madness and if you look at how this
works if you do not plot a nice graph of
this it's doubling about every seven and
a half months so the problem is that a
lot of our kit won't keep up with this a
lot of and also not only is the
individual detectors doubling but we're
getting more beam lines that are using
more of them so we've got a real data
problem here's a sort of a schematic and
these are all the different beam lines
at diamond as I say they all do
different stuff not all of them most
terrifying as that but there are quite a
few of them that are red which
collecting
not necessarily routinely but definitely
in peak over one terabyte a day at the
end of january i did an experiment on
one of the beam lines and I collected
6.8 terabytes of data in three days just
as an example of how much we can collect
last raw data and so there's these
different categories of beam lines and
different amounts of data that were
collecting obviously to deal with this
we've got data storage we've got a large
amount of data storage we spend a lot of
money on it it has to be relatively high
speed we've got several petabytes of
spinning disks we've got I think
potentially 5 petabytes of tape store to
back all this data up onto a very
important but the key problem with this
and the reason why I bring up here is
that when you start going to these
high-performance systems and you say
yeah you ask the the vendors what can I
do with this and you say oh I'd like to
put you know a couple of hundred
thousand one Meg Tiff's on to it please
they go sorry what you're not running a
database on this this really doesn't
work with small systems and then you say
and I'd like two LS that directory and
they laugh at you so actually it made a
really big mindset change we had to
completely change the way we're
collecting data we had to move a lot
more to hdf5 and single files that
contain a lot more data the problem with
hdf5 is that it's not an ASCII file and
you can't read it straight away which
causes a lot of issues for analysis I
wanted to put this up because in the
next sort of bits that I'm talking about
not all of the data I'm talking about
it's necessarily just big in terms of
volume I really like this because
everybody talks about big data in
different ways there's four V's here I
think there's another couple of these in
other people's talks but basically it
comes down to that the data can be big
because of its volume its variety just
lots of different types of data that you
have to deal with veracity how likely is
to exist be relevant those kinds of
things and velocity how quickly it comes
in so really good slider really like
this one blatantly stolen from IBM but
essentially it really does detail that a
lot of these things and not just it's
not just the shared their quantity of
data that's a problem so I'm going to
start off actually with the small data
rate beamline so these are the green
ones the less than 100 gigabytes per day
and the problem with them is variety of
later the reason they're generally low
amount of data is because they're doing
really different experiments each
experiment they do is generally
different here is a quote I haven't
named them to keep them anonymous from
one of the principal beamline scientists
on one of those beam lines so I have all
the data I've ever collected on a floppy
disk and process it by hand that was in
2005 and it was completely accurate
unfortunately detectors new improvements
and stuff he's collected about one
terabyte so far this year it's a
completely different set up for him you
know literally ten years ago he was able
to do all of his processing and stuff
like Excel was absolutely no issue with
that at all you pop a column of data no
issues whatsoever yeah matlab IDL igor
pray these are all rather these were
really good pieces of software and they
work really really well if your problem
can be contained on your laptop but as
soon as it starts getting bigger these
become more difficult to scale and
change the title is slightly because
processing data isn't always entirely
true it's generally playing around with
data I investigating what's going on and
the key issue here is scalability it's
very difficult to take things like
MATLAB and a reasonable price make them
scale across a cluster unfortunately we
don't get academic licenses on that lab
even though we're academic so it costs
us an absolute fortune for every license
and that license and MATLAB we have very
very inefficient to put on our cluster
so talking of clusters we've got a
reasonable number of these we have them
locally so that we can process stuff
real time it's really important we've
got instant access to these clusters
they're not massive they're not really
you know they're not tops of 500 super
computer clusters but they're reasonably
a reasonably big and they're very much
tailored for batch processing because
that's what we do we do only have a lot
of data or not to batch process it most
of our stuff is embarrassingly parallel
hence the GPU clusters very good sorry
this slide was also stolen cuz I love
the fact that people put the number of
cores on the GPUs always makes it look
really impressive um so pythons the
obvious answer the users have already
used it during their beam time because
they've used items they know the
syntactic problems they know that they
need to use spaces and not tabs or the
other way around it's free and easily
distributable we can put it across our
whole cluster and there's no additional
cost and
not going to tell you what the other
amazing reasons for using Python arc has
been the entire conference on it but we
want to give it to them in a way that
they can understand and that they they
used to because as I say some of these
guys have got very little experience so
the key way or the easiest way for us to
do that was to extend our acquisition
tools luckily in about 2010 the GDA went
into a new part of new system in Java
cornu finger java called eclipse so it's
it now written in the eclipse RCP
framework and it made it very easy at
about the same time our team split from
just data acquisition to data
acquisition and scientific computing as
a separate group and at that point it
was very easy to create a spin-off
product that basically took the bits of
the analysis and the visualization from
the GDA and provided in a way that users
could take home with them or use in a
separate way as I say also added a few
things like reading and writing for
different file formats various other
bits and pieces the reason I bring up
here is because it's what we now use as
our main sort of environment for
developing Python in terms of the bits
that are really relevant for Python we
use pydev really heavily so we put a lot
of effort and we used a really great
contractor Jonah from Quechua to put a
lot of information into or a lot of
additional features into pie dough
scripting to make it more interactive
and I hear that there's some people who
are doing some more work on making point
of Python stuff work even better so it's
really good that that's sort of starting
to kick off pydev is really excellent by
the way it's a very very really
efficient ide for generating stuff we
also have a lot of data exploring hdf5
visualization as standard because of
course that's what we're collecting all
our data too so we need to show that and
we've got various ways of tying our
Python to that visualization because I
believe there was going to be a talk
this morning about how there's no
visualization packages for Python so
we've got another one here the only deal
was we didn't really want to recreate
matplotlib or anything like this but we
already had a full visualization system
that was quite interactive so you can do
things like peak fitting and function
fitting and stuff just in the GUI and it
was what our users were already used to
using so hence we didn't feel too bad
replica
a load of stuff the plotting is one
thing just to give you a few ideas of
what of how pydev works and as I say
it's incorporated into our project
interactive console we've got real time
variable view ipython interface which is
quite nice they can use a reasonable
number of your magic functions integrate
debugging you can pop a breakpoint in
places even in the interactive console
and it will stop on that breakpoint late
step through all kinds of useful things
syntax highlighting scripting tools
loads and loads of really cool features
well worth being aware of it if nothing
else and it's a really really very good
a good set of tools as I say it's
incorporated in our product in dawn but
you can just get it on its own it's very
very good so in terms of the python that
we use at diamond just to give you an
idea of libraries and stuff like this so
we use the Anaconda distribution now
very convenient for us to install and we
mainly use it for the classic stuff none
by side by age five PI MPI for pi we
find really useful for our cluster and
also we've got a few other tool boxes in
there you may or may not have heard
about Astra's a kind of a wrapper on to
the astra toolbox for doing tomography
work we use the wrapper for fftw and we
use CCTV X which is a crystallography
toolkit I'll talk a little bit more
about that later but essentially what
this means is that very very relatively
easily we've moved from these guys who
want to play with their experimental
data rather than using MATLAB IDL and
having issues with support and issues
with portability a lot of them are now
starting to use Python it makes life a
lot easier for us to support and what as
a group we're trying to do is basically
to give them access to modules to make
life easier for them but also apply
things like repositories training
because essentially if they can write
software that's actually going to be
sustainable and I will point out dude go
and have a chat with the guys from the
same software sustainability Institute
if you haven't already so very very
useful information on how to basically
make sure that your code can actually
live longer than your existing project
but basically trying to keep those kinds
of features in place is really important
so that's what we're providing to them
but essentially means that they can go
off and do all their data processing
themselves
as a slight aside and apologize to
people who went to your si pie 2012
because I did talk about this a little
bit then but a little bit of an update
on this we do also use Python for other
things so with the machine if you
remember when we were wiggling those
electrons left to right in the video at
the beginning it's one of the things
that we do to generate these really
bright light sources and so rather than
data processing using Python for
optimization is really important here's
what one of those insertion devices
looks like in reality it's about 600
magnets on the top and the bottom and
they form a really nice array any
problem is that the individual magnets
can't be manufactured perfectly i mean
there's about 20,000 or sorry 200,000
pounds worth of magnets there you can't
make loads and loads of them and pick
the best ones so you've got they're not
always brilliant so the perfect one
obviously would be exactly in the
direction the magnetic field exactly in
the direction you've machined it to and
they're always off by a few percent so
it's a simple optimization problem you
just need to take those 800 magnets pick
six hundred of them in the right order
and create a perfect magnet array from
it the only issue is that the the range
of the magnetic field is quite high so
it actually becomes a really really very
complicated problem which you can use
various different optimization
techniques to to address one of the plus
points was that we had some code in
Fortran already it was a little bit hard
to use it was a bit difficult to extend
the key thing with optimization problems
is a really good talk on optimization
yesterday and is objective functions and
how long it takes you to calculate your
problem so we need to calculate the
entire magnetic field for this system
based on all of the different magnets
and then effectively model what electron
would do as it moves through it so
original code was about a thousand times
slower than Python or even fortran code
because it was almost a direct port we
didn't use anything clever it was a load
of if loops numpy put all into the
optimized arrays and we were about ten
times slower the thing that was
interesting though was that by the time
we've done this in the code the Python
was so much cleaner and so much easier
to see and understand them the Fortran
it was really obvious to notice that
there was some caching that we could do
that brought up the speed to basically
the same as the fortress
and in fact by using some clever
updating we could get about 100 times
faster if you're at the presentation a
euro side pie they said four hundred
times faster this is why you should
never use your benchmarking tests to
show slides on when we actually did the
real thing actually ended up tlie not
quite as efficient as we were hoping but
even so is a significant improvement in
time the other thing that we then did
was basically used instead of simulated
annealing which was all the old fortran
code used we used a global optimizer
part of called artificial immune systems
so that's just slightly below genetic
algorithms if you have no real clue
about what your problem is but know that
crossover won't work very well you use
artificial immune systems they're pretty
good for that needs a lot more
evaluations but gives us a much better
result the key was though instead of
millions of iterations we wanted to do
hundreds of millions of thousands of
millions of iterations so we looked a
little bit of parallelization very very
simple paralyzation in this case we just
used threading and numpy numpy releases
the Gil for all of its operations so you
can just use the standard threading
library to process across very very easy
use we got you know almost a perfect
scaling on our cluster and then we used
MPI for pi to paralyze across multiple
machines maybe we quite happily run this
on 25 machines that 200c can use really
get the speed that we wanted to make
leave the whole process very very quick
and the nice thing is that literally
since January the first sort with this
new code has now been used and it's now
been built into a system so we're kind
of committed to this now and it's
working really nicely so back to our
sort of high data rate beam lines we're
not going to look at the things that are
generating more than one terabyte a day
and this is really the domain rather
than the scientists basically who are
playing around with the data this is
really about data reduction data
processing so the first thing we need to
do is archived the data and in fact you
would have think this was quite a simple
task we need to communicate with a web
server somewhere and tell it what the
data is we need to give it some
information about metadata and stuff
like this but actually we need to check
to make sure the file really exists we
need to check sizes we need to collect
information and in fact it turned out to
be reasonably complicated problem
so as an example of where we're using
Python as a kind of a routine script
here basically this just collects all
the information from various different
files there's a bit of XML parsing make
sure that file sizes match up and these
kinds of things talks to web services
there's all sorts of things like this it
scales nicely onto the cluster which is
very very useful and we've based the
archive pretty much all of our petabyte
of archive data so far through this
system so it's relatively happy with
dealing with the 200 million files or so
that we've we've had to process
basically it's not really dealing with
much of the data but it's having to deal
with the fact that we've got large
amounts of data is sort of lying around
in terms of actually processing these
things the the red beam lines at the top
here are the MX village that's
macromolecular crystallography these
guys got very very fast detectors and
they do things like drug discovery and
drug development the way that we use
Python in these situations is actually
as more of a pipelining system there's a
lot of software available for doing all
of these sort of internal steps but a
lot of the software is single core not
necessarily paralyzed written in Fortran
not particularly reliable all kinds of
these sorts of things that are a bit
annoying to run it on a production
system so what we do is we've got two
different pipelines the first one fast
DP which runs it basically takes all of
this data so they can collect something
like about eight or nine gigabytes of
data in about a minute it takes that
data and then paralyze it across most of
our cluster does all these various steps
on different programs and then combines
all the data back together makes the
best estimates it can uses some other
programs to adjust things but
essentially at the end of the process
it's taking all of this data using
Python to paralyze it across all these
different machines and it's taking us
down to a single output file the nice
thing about macromolecular
crystallography is that eight terabytes
goes in the top and about 100 Meg comes
out the bottom really nice for data
reduction at the same time as that's
happening that takes about two minutes
at the same time we use a different
program called zrt behind the scenes
it's using all the same things to call
the cluster so it's really nice to code
reuse but this is an expert system what
this tries to do is solve your problem
has a human would and try and get either
best
all possible this result is the quick
result this one is the the high quality
result this takes about 20-30 minutes so
it's not so important but if you really
notice that actually fast if he hasn't
given you the result you want you can
then use the the results afterwards this
is done completely automatically for the
user it's really important the next step
is experimental phasing and this is
taking that tens of megs of data and
it's putting it through once again we
throw it out to pretty much the entire
cluster we're making use of the fact
that we know that we don't know a lot
about necessarily the system but we know
that it's got to have some stuff in it
if we basically make a matrix of all the
things that can be in there and solve
all of them and then pick the one with
the least error we're probably on to a
good winner and this can basically
reduce the data down to a electron
density map which is what you want at
the end of this this is an atomic
resolution map of the protein or
whatever you're interested in looking at
thank you and as we go through that
process and once again this isn't so
much the amount of data because we've
already reduced it quite heavily but
it's the speed it's the velocity that we
need to deal with and the whole nice
thing about this is it takes about
another two minutes and this is one of
the reasons why we've got such a big
cluster sat next to all of the data so
that we can process these things so
quickly so from putting the sample on
the beam line and pressing the Go button
they can pretty much automatically have
within five minutes a atomic
representation of the structure they're
interested in that's really important
for the years very very useful feature
I've only talks about using Python as a
as a kind of glue language for making
things useful we're starting to move on
to using Python as or more actually for
writing the software that we're doing so
dolls is a project that basically is
looking at taking a lot of those blocks
that I told you where single core were
not very reliable and writing better
software based on that it's got four
full-time developers it's an EU grant
basically that runs through its built on
top of this CCTV a crystallographic
toolkit which they're extending and
working very closely with and it uses
basically we're trying to do this
optimization only when required so
everything is written in Python when we
know that everything is working
correctly you identify what's slow and
then they use the boost libraries to
basically
right the rest of it down in C so that
you get the nice performance
improvements the reason they chose boost
was because it's tied in quite heavily
with the CCTV ex-library they were works
very nicely so this is an example of
where we're basically not only using
Python for pipelining but also for
actually doing data processing I mean
this will have to deal with them have to
compete with fortran code c code so it
has to be a reasonably high performance
and i think the way that it's working is
that it's a you know it's close enough
that it's not a problem so finally I'm
going to talk about tomography data
reconstruction this is mainly volume and
velocity the problem with these guys is
that they collect maybe 100 gigabytes
per data set and it gets reconstructed
to about a hundred gigabytes per data
set is imaging data so once again we're
in a very similar situation to MX we've
got some C code that uses curiosity the
reconstructions but it only runs on
tiffs it only uses one GPU it doesn't
really correct for all the experimental
artifacts properly so we wrap it up in
Python that enables us to split the data
and use the whole cluster it allows us
to extract the corrected data from the
hdf5 files using h 5 pi and rewrite them
as Tiff's on to the local file system
for this program to use and it basically
builds input files from the metadata so
the user doesn't have to specify all of
this information because when we collect
the data we include enough information
with that in the collected files so this
is very much this runs quite heavily as
I say it's running on large quantities
of data but it's only wrapping up what's
going on the next generation of
tomography unfortunately these guys
decided that it would be really nice to
be able to process the data so you've
got 100 gigabyte volume of data they
want to process it in one direction and
then process it in the other direction
which means we're effectively got to
transpose the matrix and do transfer
between all the different nodes of our
cluster so essentially to do that we're
looking at using MPI for pie for the
cluster organization and queuing and
parallelism but then using zeromq and
using blazquez the transfer mechanism to
try and compress the data as we transfer
it across currently we're still going to
be using the external codes but the idea
is to move them into Python as soon as
possible because there are some really
good libraries in Python for doing
reconstruction most kinds of things
and they're a lot of them are basically
making calls to the GPU and to be honest
in terms of performance it doesn't
really matter if you're calling q de
code from C or Python or Fortran it's
still calling q2 code on the card so it
makes very little difference to the
performance somebody brought up the
concert in there's a profiling talk
yesterday and I added these slides in
very briefly this was my answer to how
to deal with profiling on multiprocessor
and MPI systems so basically all I
wanted to do was basically see where
things were how things were running in
parallel and the thing I really noticed
was using threading and multiprocessing
was that because my h 5 pi process was
holding on to the gill i can get it to
stop doing that i got this very
distinctive tick in all the rest of my
processes whenever they actually got a
couple of seconds to run various
different things on the queuing system
and all these kinds of things so
actually was really useful having this
kind of diagram that basically displayed
so these four threads or four threads
that are running on one processor or one
machine these for the next machine and
the next machine it's not quite as fine
grains as proper profiling it's
basically based on log messages but at
least it gives you an idea of what's
going on and when I looked at it with
just the MPI I got a much better
alignment I didn't have a lot of these
blocking issues so that's why we're
we're choosing MPI now as I say I use
these graphs structures quite a lot now
and it suddenly hit me I mean this was
very much it was a case of using some
Java scripts they talked to yesterday as
well javascript so just ease the Google
visualization data table just as a way
of displaying the data I basically just
set up my login configure the few bits
of information in there so that whenever
I call logging message from MPI it just
includes the machine number and it
includes a rank for the machine or you
can include the thread name if you want
to depend on what mechanism using and
then I just use ginger to templating to
basically to tie the two together to
produce an output it just takes my log
file converts it into an HTML file I can
just view that and see what's going on
with my process because it's a damn
sight easier than grapping out okay
process five core three it's a real
nightmare to grab that sort of
information out and see what's going on
especially when you're trying to relate
to other things anyway where are we
going so from my point of view with the
amount of data we're collecting
scientists have to become developers the
idea from our point of view is to try
and steer them in the right direction so
they're doing a good job rather than
just hacking code together and at the
end of the day python is a very good if
not the best tool for this there's no
other system out there that we've found
that allows scientists to use the or
allow them to do as much as as much they
can in Python that easily and the next
step is that developers having to work
faster and faster weird basically
there's 12 of us we've got to support a
hundred different techniques we've only
got maybe a couple of days to sort out
one of these techniques so we have to be
able to implement it very very quickly
and Python really does allow that and
for anything that we're running on the
cluster and a computational techniques
we generally look at driving them in
Python pythons I'll go to language for
doing most of these things if its
graphical acceptable II we use Java but
so gooeys and stuff we're still using
Java but for a lot of the core under the
hood stuff cluster stuff we're using
Python ninety percent of the slides and
stuff here are stolen from other people
so I'd like to acknowledge them all the
ones that were spelled correctly were at
least all of them other people and thank
you all for listening